esto es lo que queda de la cuenta del
presidente de donald trump twitter tomó
la decisión de suspenderla
permanentemente argumentando que hay
riesgo de una mayor incitación a la
violencia el mandatario es señalado de
alentar a sus seguidores a tomarse el
capitolio un episodio que dejó un saldo
de cinco muertos dejamos en claro hace
años que estas cuentas no están por
encima de nuestras reglas y no pueden
usar twitter para incitar a la violencia
de acuerdo con twitter dos de los
últimos tuits de trump infringen sus
políticas de admiración a la violencia
antes la compañía solo se había limitado
a etiquetar u ocultar sus tweets por ser
un funcionario gubernamental había
estado exento de ser vetados de la
plataforma al considerar que su
contenido es de interés público pero
twitter también deja claro que esto no
significa que cualquier funcionario
público es elegible para tuitear lo que
quiera especialmente cuando el riesgo de
daño es mayor o más severo a través de
la cuenta oficial de la presidencia
trump refutó las medidas pero sus
publicaciones fueron eliminadas
creo que las acciones del presidente el
miércoles mostró al mundo el peligro de
mantener el control de este mecanismo de
medios sociales hay que recordar el
donald trump casi inventó el estilo de
liderar un país por twitter con más de
88 millones de seguidores twitter era la
red social favorita del presidente
emitía decenas de trinos diarios y había
utilizado su cuenta para anunciar sus
decisiones e incluso despedir a sus
funcionarios
trump aún tiene acceso a las cuentas de
la casa blanca y de la presidencia pero
lo perderá cuando finalice su mandato el
20 de enero un portavoz de la compañía
advirtió que cualquier cuenta que sea
creada para evadir la suspensión también
sería eliminada